good morning Millennials happy Monday
welcome back to the morning toast it's a
beautiful Monday of day one of Phase two
in New York City hey Claude hid hey Jax
I am good I'm feeling like refreshen
also exhausted it's a unique combination
one in which I'm really not used to but
I did a lot more than the average
weekend this weekend you know yeah same
I should be feeling refresh I'm mostly
feeling exhausted like I'm kind of
feeling like the shot vibe today the
20-minute shot the shot vibe the this
show in which we do not speak I'm not
there yet but Jackie and I were finally
able to get out of the city for a few
days this weekend we decided last minute
to go to the Hamptons
they had like other parts of New York
are in different phases they're a little
bit further along in terms of returning
to normalcy and it was just it was
stellar
it was stellar it was everything of a
sort like I definitely abused you know
my new privileges of like being out
sitting outside with a mask 6 feet on at
a restaurant I abuse it I got so drunk
like every single woman I was in the
presence of a bar um and I have
absolutely no regrets I'm just like
tired but um I don't know I feel like
yesterday was Father's Day and usually
I'm like cool but like yesterday was
like a really hard terrible day yeah
well I think it was just like a hard day
period between you know going from such
a high and like alcohol and then coming
back to the city and getting back into
your little cage here it's just a lot
and I think was just emotional um and
they we're coming off of just an
emotional few months and it's just a lot
for one person to handle totally so I
think I think that's therapy to feel
that way we did have a quite a lovely
weekend enjoying phase 2 elsewhere and
now we get to enjoy phase 2 here and I
don't even know where to start I don't
know where to start I downloaded the
Citizen AB and it has really become just
like my ear to the ground because today
they sent out like it's not just like a
notifications ever sale so like a little
blog and they like send out like details
of things that they think that you
should know and today was just all
without phase two and it was just so
many things I didn't know like salons
are open but you can't have a waiting
room and everyone s wear masks obviously
on alfresco dining sitting six feet
apart only outside it's just there were
so many things that I didn't know gyms
unfortunately are still closed which is
really hard for me but I have a feeling
I'm gonna survive we'll be here for you
we will be here for you um I would
actually love to get a pedicure it's
like maybe that's in my future this week
I don't know it's also exciting I don't
I really don't know like what to do
first I think al fresco dining would be
first but I'm scared scared of Wyatt
leaving my house like I've really grown
accustomed to my little cage my cell and
I don't want to leave no I know it's
gonna be like a shock to this positional
transitional yeah exactly so we gotta
ease our way into it and I'm just I'm so
excited hopeful optimistic and excited
about being in Phase two for those who
are listening who might you know live in
a state that's way ahead of us like this
may sound trivial but you just don't
understand like what it's been like and
just be happy for us yeah we're so happy
so just be happy for us anyways we've
agreed so free today it's a very
exciting Monday we have so much to talk
about like it stays too and we have so
much to talk about we have so much to
talk about like we we got a peak at
civilization over the weekend and I just
feel like I have a whole new perspective
on the entire world and everyone in it
I also spent last night watching Jeff
mercy which was our twist movie of the
week which we will recap and then we
will also assign our next movie and for
those who've been listening to the toast
for the last few months I did something
over the weekend that might shock you
because I finally finished Jessica
Simpson's [ __ ] textbook of a book it
was huge for injure pages it's like I
don't even know the last time I read
something that long but boy was it worth
it and we will discuss that as well
because I have thoughts about it I'm so
glad that you finally read it that we
can finally talk about it in all its
glory I read two books this weekend both
fabulous books that I would recommend
that we'll recap at the end but I read
Andre Leon Talley
um the chiffon trenches memoir
and Gabrielle unions were gonna need
more wine mem are both so good can't
wait to discuss love that for you so I
feel like it's kind of busy day yeah I
feel like it might be time I haven't
laid eyes on the prize yet yep though
and sometimes that that like fuels my
participation in the show so is Ted or
around the prize man is with his father
on a walk and he's not here so sorry
that's so upsetting I mean I haven't
haven't seen Mindy's I think he
literally just got back I heard the door
I told my feel the auntie's love okay
it's just so perfect but yes I I do
agree I doubt the read let's jump right
in to the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and that's true Jax but if everyone
could pan their screen to my left you'll
see today's sponsor the hush blanket
which is absolutely everything of this
sort and everything I needed in
quarantine and Beyond quarantine it has
helped me so much
so basically hush blankets makes
weighted blankets but you have a ton of
benefits they can help with anxiety um
they can help you fall asleep long or
they keep you warmer it's just it's such
a fabulous product and I happen to have
like the cutest one Jackie and I
actually wasn't the UM the same one it's
the velvet blue one times are extremely
stressful especially with what's going
on in the world people are experienced
stress experiencing stress and anxiety
about many things and their goal at hush
blankets is to provide a sense of relief
the hush weighted blanket will help you
relax stay calm and it'll feel feel like
a big hug you can have a deeper sleep
you can stay sleep longer and there's
also proven to help people who
experience anxiety and stress I can 100%
attest to the back like it works it's
crazy plus hutch blank hutch blankets
has a give back program where they
donate one in a ten one in ten adult
blankets and one in five kids blankets
to charities and shelters in need it's
been a huge part of their brand since
day one they can understand that not
everyone can afford a hush blanket but
they absolutely deserve to experience a
better sleep they also have a 100 night
guarantee where they return an exchange
process is super easy you have a hundred
nights to test out your blanket if you
don't love it send it back for a full
refund no questions asked if you feel
like it's too heavy or too light you can
exchange sizes so Jack and I both have
the throw blanket
they have tons of different options in
terms of size and in terms of weight
because you know people weigh different
things so someone needs someone having
something heavier someone needs
something lighter it's actually the only
one that I've seen that has adjustable
and customizable weights inside the
blanket so if you want to get a plush
blanket you can use the code toast
for 10% off all the weighted blankets at
hush blankets calm so the code is toast
toas tea for 10% off all weighted
blankets at hush blankets calm thank you
much blankets for sponsoring today's
episode of hush blankets ok first story
some sweet news Gabrielle unions new
self magazine cover shoot was
photographed by xiah Wade she says I'm
beyond proud nothing but praise
Gabrielle Union looks stunning in the
June digital issue of self and has her
stepdaughters I await to think the
breaking in actress took to Instagram on
Thursday she shares several photos that
the thirteen-year-old took of her for
self magazine quote beyond proud of zai
awaits shooting her first cover she
captioned the post she is a tremendous
artist / writer and I'm so happy
everyone gets a glimpse of what she can
do seeing yourself through a child's
eyes is quite illuminating and I'm
grateful we got this opportunity from
self magazine in a separate post
Gabrielle Union raves about the poolside
photos from saya shoot that didn't make
the cut but she was sharing them as well
I absolutely love the photos no I mean
this whole concept is so cute like the
fact that her stepdaughter is now like
technically like a magazine published
photographer when photography is
obviously like a huge passion of hers
like that is iconic iconic and it's a
great way to get like crafty in the cue
you know setting up at home photoshoots
having your family members participate
especially one with an artistic eye I
think this is so fabulous what a great
opportunity for Ziya and the photos are
amazing so everyone wins
I feel like recently like when I've been
reading or reporting on Gabrielle Union
and Dwyane Wade it's like mostly about
their parenting skills and from what
I've seen they are like the world's best
parents yeah well you know since reading
her book I have like a whole new
appreciation for her and her role as a
stepmother and
as a mirin in general and it's not
something she takes lightly and she's
really wonderful at it and here's just
another example you know ya know I
thought this was like a very cool
creative thing for her to do and I'm
just so excited hi Theo he's back from
his walk I'm so excited that like her
stepdaughter now is like maybe she'll
get other gigs ya know this could be
like the beginning of a big career it
could be the start of something new so
right to be here with you
it just feels so right to be here with
you um what did you think about her
Brooke I loved it I've always liked very
much like to Gabrielle Union like love
which she's about of her films but I got
to know so much more of her personality
and she's so cool and just funny and
with it and she wrote a lot about her
childhood and it was so interesting like
I feel like she wrote more about who she
was before she was famous then then she
did post Fame and I loved reading about
every minute of it she talked a lot
about like being black in Hollywood and
all of the different um like diversity
in Hollywood about Princess Parties and
how so much of like diversity in
Hollywood is about like who you hang out
with to begin with you know and she meet
like she just spoke on so many different
subjects in such an interesting and
enlightening way and I'm so I'm so glad
that I read it and that she wrote it
what did she say about bring it on oh
okay she said like well she had like the
nicest things to say about ten Things I
Hate About You she talked about that
first and she said that it was really
like it was like camp like the kids were
all like going out together there's such
good friends everyone had such a good
time she said like the sweetest things
about Heath Ledger that he was just like
such a great guy um and then she said
bring it on was similar except that um
Kirsten Dunst was like younger than
everyone she stayed in the house with
her mom while the rest of them I think
right the hotel so her mommy's like have
barbecues for the crew but everyone
would be like where we going after this
because she was like still so young so
ever really it was like so cute yeah
everyone was really close but kirsten
was a little too young to be so friendly
with them because they really go into
bars and stuff so that was attitude from
that but also what I thought was
interesting is like whenever someone
comes up to her from bring it on a lot
of the time self they'll repeat this
line to her which is it's already been
brought in but that's not a line from
bring it on it's from I believe not
another teen movies from a spoof of
bring it on until like that's what yeah
and she talks about how like perception
is reality and people just assume that
guys from ran on and that's her line and
it's not even in the original movie oh
man I totally thought it was yeah you
know I didn't think it was because
that's not how it was written but
everyone knows that one from not another
teen movie where they're just like
spoofing bring it on it's already been
broughten interesting I love this cheese
spoke about like that time I mean her
like I didn't know some people like hate
to [ __ ] they love to shy away some like
the thing that made them famous I mean I
don't want to talk about it they don't
address it like Hannah Montana you know
but so I love when people lean into it
cuz those are the stories like we want
to hear yeah she's leaning into
everything she's also so honest like
honest about how she sometimes has felt
like you know not wanting to help the
person coming up behind her and you know
feeling jealous but also ultimately
realizing that that is how like she was
just really honest about like any
thoughts she's had and I thought that it
it was fabulous oh that's so fabulous
and so is her health cover yes and so is
her self cover um and if you love the
celebrity memoir I definitely recommend
Gabrielle unions and it's also a series
of short stories which is a great way to
read a book it's just like so snackable
yes I agree I love short essays okay our
next story I just want to share a
trigger warning we're gonna be talking
about sexual assault for this story and
the next story
but Angela Elgort is denying sexual
assault allegations he said I have never
and would never assault anyone Ansel
Elgort has denied allegations that he
sexually assaulted a 17 year old girl
earlier this week a Twitter user named
Gabby shared a since deleted post in
which she alleged the baby driver actor
had sexually assaulted her in 2014 when
she was 17 she also alleged that he
tried to solicit
nude photos from her and asked to have a
threesome in a statement shared on his
Instagram account on Saturday he denied
the allegations quote I was distressed
to see the social media posts about me
that have been circulating in the past
24 hours I cannot claim to understand
what Gabby's feelings but her
description of events is simply not what
happened
I had never and would never assault
anyone what is true is that in New York
in 2014 when I was 20 Gabby and I had a
brief legal an entirely consensual
relationship unfortunately I did not
handle the break-up well I stopped
responding to her which is an immature
and cruel thing to do to someone I know
this belated apology does not absolve me
of my unacceptable behavior when I
disappeared as I look back at my
attitude I am disgusted and deeply
ashamed of the way I acted I'm truly
sorry I know I must continue to reflect
learn and work to grow in empathy woof
that is that's just not um ideal and
this is kind of uh this was the first of
a fika where I think that this girl
speaking out really inspired other
people to speak out about their
experiences with celebrities and non
celebrities alike this kind of started a
chain which is really great but in terms
of Ansel Elgort I just um I'm sure like
I it's interesting um that he responded
so quickly and very informally as well
like in a note screenshot like this I
just thought maybe he would I don't know
like go on the view you know yeah or
have a publicist statement but I mean
he's I think taking straight to
Instagram and talking to your fans is a
good way I agree it is it is a good way
to go I was reading the comments on his
post just because I I just wanted to
like gauge the temperature of what
people were saying and somebody wrote a
really interesting comment and was
basically just like just because you
don't think you did anything wrong
doesn't mean that you did that's true
and it's like I feel like in this
situation he like he just didn't bother
to realize anything was wrong do you
know what I mean yeah that's a very good
point I'm like part of that is just
being a celebrity and thinking you can
do it
you want but not like realizing how
other people are feeling about it yeah
then just other people were coming
forward that like they had spoken to him
on like his weird private snapchat and
like honestly the screenshots like we're
really embarrassing he was like acting
like a two-year-old like talking to
children online like it was really
predatory concerning behavior and like
it was embarrassing for him yeah I mean
it's not good for him um my heart goes
out to girl named Gabby because that's a
lot to go through at 17 I mean it's very
hard to speak up about sexual assault
especially when the person who assaulted
you is rich and famous it's like no one
wants to cross that that's like what the
whole Jeffrey Epstein documentary was
like yeah going up against like this
rich and powerful person and it's very
intimidating and I think it was really
brave of her to share her story and it
inspired I sucked people commenting on
the threads just talking for the first
time in their own lives about their own
sexual assault it was it was very brave
and it's um it's just a terrible story
yeah it's a terrible story but similarly
Justin Bieber is refuting sexual assault
allegations saying sexual abuse is
something I don't take lightly just
right Justin Bieber has produced
screenshots of emails and hotel receipts
to refute a sexual assault claim posted
Saturday by an anonymous Twitter user on
Saturday evening a Twitter user under
the name Danielle who chose to keep her
last name anonymous alleged that she was
sexually assaulted by the singer in 2014
when she was 21 and he was 20 the tweet
and the account were later removed from
Twitter she alleged that she met Bieber
while attending an event in Texas and
claimed that she and her friends were
invited back to his hotel where she was
sexually assaulted without consent
Danielle did not identify the friends
and has not otherwise spoken publicly
about the claim after the Twitter
account was removed ding was not able to
be reached right people for additional
comments Justin Bieber said I don't
normally address things as I have dealt
with random accusations my entire career
but after talking with my wife and team
I have decided to speak up on an issue
tonight
he said rumors are rumors for sexual
abuse is not something I do I
is something I don't take lightly I
wanted to speak out right away but out
of respect to so many victims who deal
with these issues I wanted to make sure
I gathered the facts before I made any
statement in the past 24 hours a new
Twitter appeared that told a story of
myself involved with sexual abuse and I
want to be clear there is no truth to
this story in fact as I will soon show I
was never present at that location um he
shared several posts on Twitter
including links to articles from the
time period in addition to proof of
receipts and emails to deny these
allegations they also he also said we
confirmed with the Four Seasons regional
manager that I was never on the property
on March 9th of 2014 never a guest on
the 9th or the temped and I welcome all
press to enquire with them it's needed
or wanted I mean he [ __ ] went in on
those receipts like those screenshots
like those are from [ __ ] 10 years ago
like he and his team you know scooter on
doesn't sleep like they did their
[ __ ] work just as for Selena Gomez
who's getting dragged into this when
like really how is she oh so he said he
tweeted about her multiple times last
night saying that they were together for
the concert and like he was with her the
whole night so like now it's like she's
a witness and it's like she had such a
tumultuous relationship with him that
like now she's being dragged into it in
such a negative way like leave her out
of this oh wow yeah I didn't see how she
was but it always comes back to the two
of them yeah I just I feel really sad
for um the girl because she's obviously
like freaking out because like speaking
up is such a brave thing to do and then
immediately like you have the Beliebers
on your ass and then Justin Bieber like
tweeting about you like any and I'm sure
she's young like any person would freak
out and like delete their account so I
just can't imagine what she's feeling
like right now um it's just not not good
no it's not good but he's not taking
this lightly as he says no he is not
okay next story a little more happy news
a little more quarantined developments
because Live Nation is setting a
drive-in concert series
amid the pandemic tour motor yet it
sounds exciting to our promoter Live
Nation's announced its first-ever
driving concert series in the US
for July months after the live music
industry has been on lockdown the
entertainment company on Monday
announced live from the drivin a set of
nine shows to take place July 10 through
12 in Nashville Maryland Heights
Missouri and Noblesville Indiana Brad
Paisley will headline the show in all
three cities while fellow country artist
Darius Rucker and John party will also
perform in Nashville at Nissan Stadium
Nelly will perform in Maryland Heights
near st. Louis so concert concert goers
will able to drive into the parking lots
of amphitheaters a maximum of four
people per car and will have to empty
parking lot spaces in between the two
vehicles so fans can watch and party
from their designated individual
tailgating zones so weird but actually I
think about it it is it's like a
tailgate yeah it sounds funny I mean
it's something to do it's better than
nothing and we were just saying how we
would give anything to be at a concert
these days and so honestly a concert
from the comfort of your own heart car
where you'll have a seat you have AC
like I'm kind of here for this no I
totally love this idea and I'm just
about to see something so controversial
like maybe the most controversial thing
maybe not but a very controversial thing
I love this idea I just don't get why
it's really being built around Brad
Paisley and I just love country music
actually really don't like Brad Paisley
like I don't like his music I don't like
his vibe I don't like when he hosts like
I just I get that he's like a staple of
Nashville and like I'm country music but
like I don't subscribe to that era time
I'm just saying shots fired shots fired
I think that's fair there's obviously
Live Nation has done their research
they've spoken to the focus groups and
the focus groups are turning up for Brad
Paisley and they don't care whether
you're there or not
well I'm just saying but I obviously
didn't talk to me because like I
actually like bothers me like do you
know they mean yeah I understand there's
also a jackhammer like outside my window
phase to what's good what's so okay
great I'm glad you don't hear it yeah no
I understand like and honestly I'm
actually glad that it's like Brad
Paisley because I didn't see like a New
York City edition of this concert series
um where we all getting an uber and go
so so I'm not missing anything and I'm
happy for
those by measly fans who are getting a
little bit of the pays yeah no that's
true like I'm honestly glad that it's
him because now I don't want to go you
know I would have to fly to Nashville if
it was like Luke Combs oh my god if it
was Luke Holmes we would be like getting
a rental car
no in our wedding RV I wonder if they
had we could only have four people they
definitely have size requirement so you
can't put an RV like that in the middle
of a Congress work what about a stretch
limousine oh that that could be no you
only get two you only get one parking
spot it has to fit Japanese a car that
has to fit in a parking spot all right
so we'll get like a suburban we get a
pickup truck and lay in the flatbed and
make up a hot tub make a pool in the in
the bed of the truck
yeah actually a great idea I hope that
they do more genres like maybe hip hop
or pop anyone but Brad Paisley and I
hope they do it in New York cuz I would
definitely go yeah me and my uber driver
would just turn up like otherwise how am
I getting there yeah Jackie doesn't have
a license that's true or car that'd be
fun you take your goober driver out for
a date night love it okay are you ready
for a kaatham final story use me mama
mia producer teases or threatens a third
film saying it's meant to be a trilogy
oh my god I feel like we've said this on
the show before and it was really met
with a lot of backlash for like Mamma
Mia the Amanda Seyfried like Meryl
Streep to a movie like is the definition
of nothing of the sort
literally it's a piece of [ __ ] yeah well
judy kramer a producer behind their
original stage production is threatening
don't that can do it so um yeah I'm very
I'm like pretty anti Mamma Mia um and I
think it stems from like this place of
like I live for a movie musical you
could put anything in front of me and as
long as I can sing and dance along like
I will love it and there's just
something about Mamma Mia
that's just not it and the music is
fantastic so I'm not sure what part of
it isn't it for me but anyway
I think that like I have this
deep-rooted like childhood disdain for
Mamma Mia like now when I think about it
like there was like my friend growing up
who I don't really talk to anymore and
we don't speak of her but her and her
family were like obsessed with mommy I
like Broadway and it was like listen to
[ __ ] in the car and I couldn't relate
because I had never seen it because I
have taste and I saw better things um
and I feel like my dislike of this movie
franchise that kind of stems from that
feeling of me once feeling um like an
outcast if you know what I mean
I don't I've been going to therapy I
mean I only went once but I'm feeling
more introspective and I'm trying to
like find reasons for things so I think
the reason why I hate Mamma Mia at the
franchise is because I felt left out as
a kid when like I never like knew two
songs interesting I have I have no
explanation as to why I I don't like it
right it's very possible the movies just
garbage yeah and we also saw it on
Broadway and we loved it and then the
movie came out and it was just not it
and I just feel as though we need to
like speak up when things suck you know
we need to speak up and you know what
most importantly like we need to move
forward like we need to stop making
remakes and sequels and trickles just
[ __ ] write a new movie okay
well so the producer said she um was
meant to have been getting on with
writing a third one during these months
but then she got hit with the kovat fog
I think one day there will be another
film because there's meant to be a
trilogy you see I know Universal would
like me to do it um I had no idea that
this was meant to be a trilogy I didn't
see okay I didn't see the second one so
maybe that would explain how there could
be a third one um and the second one is
like about a young Meryl Streep played
by Lily James right you know I think
it's important to know that I've never
seen one minute of the movie or the
second movie I just know that it's bad
because like I said I have taste yeah
yeah I said what else I don't know but
you know what like a lot here's here's
my positive spin on it a lot of people
love
I don't know them but they're out there
and they might be getting a certain
movie and for y'all I'm thrilled for you
that'd be like telling me you don't want
to simulate telling me greatest showmen
is meant to be a trilogy oh I mean that
would be fantastic I don't want to sit
through like another press I don't want
to sit through like commercials and have
to see the ads like myself and and Bravo
like who had and her daughter like Mamma
Mia
Oh totally like LuAnn her daughter to
rent out her daughter like all on a
beach in Mykonos like wearing overalls
being silly I don't have to see the
movie but I can't not see like all the
incessant press that they do and so
that's what I don't want to look like
sit through I completely agree
I completely agree you said it I backed
it up therefore it is therefore it is
we're gonna dive into our TV recap and I
also want to recap Jessica Simpson's
book TV and a book recap look at us TV
and book look at us just a couple
scholars okay so let's do Jessica
Simpson first let's keep it light I know
that you told me to read it forever ago
and I know what we should I had read it
sooner because I actually like enjoyed
reading where I read I read it on the
beach this weekend so like I enjoyed the
experience and it was really um so
interesting I know I've said this before
but I've always felt dislike very
kindred deep connection to Jessica
Simpson because we shared a birthday
when I was a kid like she was everything
of the sort and like I shared a birthday
with someone who was everything of the
sort therefore by osmosis making me
everything at this order and I just feel
like this book really brought me back to
that place it's like being obsessed with
her and I learned so much about her I
mean she spilled so much and she really
didn't hold back when it came to Nick
Lachey or John Mayer which you know like
kills me um and I just love her and you
know what when I was reading it I'm like
damn there's a lot I'm here about her
childhood and normally I don't like that
[ __ ] I'm just like give me the tea I
want piping hot celebrity news but her
life was so fascinating she like grew up
in the Bible Belt of Texas they moved
all around her dad was like a big pastor
and her whole life is her it's her
church and that like she's been through
so much and she's like so beyond being
that girl she was when she
we're up on her faith it's like so
strong like how much he talks about God
and look like it just it's actually kind
of cool how she really hasn't wavered in
her faith yes I agree I just I just love
her
and what I also loved was like when she
spoke about you know newlyweds and she
was like this ditzy simple girl um she
was always in on the joke you know she
didn't people were laughing at her but
they didn't know that they were laughing
with her like she was cashing in on
being like silly like she was she and
she's not dumb she's actually very smart
if you read the book but like you said
she was just simple yeah yeah she's not
she's smart when you read the book but
like um she's like obviously just like
sometimes I was like the first thing
that you know she doesn't like think too
hard about stuff and then you get those
iconic moments like chicken of the sea
yeah some of the most to me like the
best moments were obviously the
celebrity stuff when she cried at the
Kennedy Center and then like Reese
Witherspoon and all those women took a
picture with her like I found myself
literally googling everything she spoke
about like a hundred counts on Ellen
Teen Vogue cover with Nick like I just
looked everything up she should have
provided pictures honestly yeah oh and
Andre Leon Talley spoke he provided
pictures we know what I actually liked
in for Jessica Simpson's book I liked
googling everything along with it cuz
then he would get like some accompanying
articles and it's it's good ya know I
just like loved her and honestly when
when I think about her career as a
a-hole her like pop stardom um she
definitely had more songs and I remember
like when she was listening all these
songs that were coming out like they
sounded familiar but her pop stardom was
very much like a blip on the radar
because she was coming up with Christina
Aguilera Britney Spears who kind of
seemed to outshine her and in a lot of
ways like what she ended up doing with
her career which is the Jessica Simpson
Collection which is a billion dollar
company um I just feel like she was
meant to do that
yeah but I think she also makes me you
take like just for the fun of it and
also what I found so interesting was
along the way in her career how many
like really distinguished people
respected the hell out of her like her
relationship with Willie Nelson you know
and if she if she were just like this
ditzy sort
girl like she obviously has a lot of
substance and real talent because along
the way so many people were so taken
with her in her talent um even when she
was filming like Dukes of Hazzard like
Dane Cook was you know everyone who met
it met her like fell in love with her
Johnny Knoxville oh really oh dude that
was firm like employee of the month yeah
no he's from good luck charlie or
whatever I can't no no but she was an
employee of the month and he means well
then I also forget like she had a very
um like above-average
acting career for a pop star like she
really if she had wanted to she could
have like really just become a full-time
actress she was there and multi-talented
yes she is multi-talented yeah and so
now um first of all I found the Nick
stuff to be so fascinating because when
you think of the timeline she really met
him when he was everything of the sort
and like within a matter of years he was
nothing of the sort and she was
everything of the sort and like that
balance of power and money and success
really played a part in their
relationship and honestly like in the
beginning when they were just talking
about like them getting engaged and like
married like I loved them so much they
really were like America's Sweethearts
yeah but then they both they grew into
the people they were meant to be in
those two people weren't meant to be
together yeah but it's just so crazy to
me like I think the craziest thing in
Hollywood it's like the girl that Nick
Lachey just like rebounded with ended up
being like the love of his life which it
just like doesn't happen for you and
it's weird when she's talking about her
and Nick like they were doing TRL like
they were interviewed by the net so like
a bunch of times yeah it's so weird
and then the John Mayer stuff was just
crazy like and I feel like he confirmed
like what we knew about him um he's
literally he's reformed but like back in
the day he was like a womanizer in a
piece to [ __ ] and he really just like
played with her and like really tortured
her just so he could write music which
is so [ __ ] up and then at the end it
was like was he also having sex with
Jennifer Aniston during that time period
like it was never made clear damn well
yeah I just said I know that like he
says that he's different now and he goes
on watch Rabin's five and it's like you
know a funny guy but like in that book
like he is not yeah
and I find it so interesting that she
had such an a reaction to him calling
her sexual napalm which is because she's
so rooted in her faith and then I just
remember like everyone talking about her
like virginity virginity and it really
really is what she was like it wasn't
this you know coordinated marketing
thing like she was she was this girl
yeah
yeah and and the stuff about her body
like just obviously made me love her so
much like that chili cook-off thing it's
just it's actually crazy I know it feels
like in a lot of ways like we've made no
progress but something like that like
really wouldn't have and today
and I feel like grateful it really
opened my eyes like maybe we have moved
forward as a society a little bit but I
also feel like her open struggle with
like body image paved the way for her to
have a billion dollar company like
nobody really wants to buy clothing from
someone who's perfect like because
nobody's perfect so she became this like
relatable person and I think it ended up
benefiting her in a lot of ways but I
can imagine what it was like to be so
impression well and like works so hard
to be skinny and everyone just keeps
calling you back yeah yeah so I just
thought the book was full of goodies
like celebrity goodies her family life
is so interesting I always assumed she
and Ashley had a strained relationship
and there was like some sort of jealousy
but no they are as like tight-knit as
families can come yeah she is a great
family I love that she brings everyone
from her childhood into her career now
like she's surrounded by people that
she's known forever and that she loves
and she's just like totally it's an
amazing book like cuz she's so amazing
and she's just not who you would expect
her to be and I feel like she's gone
through so much in her career but where
she is now is just like the best place
to be well Eric and sobered she talked a
lot about her struggle with booze and
pills and she even referenced coming on
Ellen totally drunk and obviously I put
the book down and I watch the interview
and I just have to say um in the book
Jessica Simpson was like I want to
apologize to Ellen into the audience
like that was not cool and I know Ellen
was just like being tough on me and it
when I watched the interview like it was
unsalvageable like she was so drunk and
wasn't making any sense it was just like
giggling all over the place
but you know Ellen could have like
helped a little bit more like she just
kept pointing out like dumb things or
like weird sounds coming out of
Jessica's mouth like really wanted to
highlight like hi you're drunk like she
wasn't not that it's her job to help but
like I don't know like you could have
minimized it a little bit and Jessica
referred to in the book is Ellen giving
her tough love but honestly like I
thought it was [ __ ] [ __ ] like I
thought she was really making more of a
spectacle out of it nothing that ever
would have gone by unnoticed I don't
know I just watch Ellen in the interview
and I was actually well not shocking
because we know Ellen yeah it was
disappointing oh I'm gonna watch you
that's one thing that I didn't watch
while I read the book yeah no it was
great um I also just can't believe that
she was married to the Met Gala like and
she took John there yeah that those
pictures are iconic
you know honestly the Cheska's Simpson
collection like needs a table at the Met
Gala like she needs to be there again
she does that I guess she doesn't care
about that stuff and that's why you love
know cuz do you know what she's rich
honey
rich and then she has a man that like
loves her what more could you need she
has wonderful children it's it's all
good you know she's really like the
ultimate success story and you might not
think that because she did kind of fade
into the background a little bit when
she was so hot for so long but like
that's you can't live in the spotlight
forever and I feel like she found a
really good balance after a while of
like family fame success fortune I think
that she is actually like a role model
for a lot of people definitely role
model for me for sure I love her I'm so
really recommend buck um and thank you
for making me because you're forcing it
down your throat
I'm admitting when I'm wrong okay um
okay so I read two books as well the
first one being Andre Leon Talley
because I wanted to read obviously I
loved her knee and I loved us-led memoir
but we are also continuing our education
I'm hearing from black creators
storytellers authors celebrities and so
I actually thought that these two books
were so perfect to read right now
because obviously they're entertaining
and enjoyable but they talked about a
lot about race and racism
in their respective industries so I'll
start with Andre Leon Talley cuz I
thought it was so fast meeting it was
just like a beauty like I can't
obviously the book was just text but
like it was beautiful the descriptions
that he talked a lot about like his
start in fashion in like the 70s and 80s
you know like Halston Siobhan Shay Saint
Laurent his friendship with Carl which I
found fascinating obviously a lot of
people talked about the friendship with
Anna Wintour and she's been in the press
a lot lately so I wanted to hear what he
had to say about her and honestly for
the most part he had glowing things to
say about her they came up together at
Vogue I mean not glowing but like they
they got they started together at Vogue
and they work together for I think about
30 years I think the way that it ended
wasn't great but she's just like
business is his business hmm um but he
just had so many like interesting
factoids and stories and there was a lot
about what I found to be interesting
there was a lot about like the past and
you know I think what they would
consider like the glory days of fashion
which were more the 80s um but not so
much about like what's going on now and
the supermodels now and and social media
and like but I think that's just because
like that was his heyday but I also felt
like it was on of a commentary I'm the
fact that like though isn't it right now
you know and he actually said that vogue
started going down the tubes the minute
they moved into one World Trade Center
because that was just like not the place
for them to be which I found to be
interesting um
but ultimately it was a great book I
feel like I've always known who Andre
Leon Talley is but I didn't know that
much about him so hearing about his
childhood in the way that he was raised
and then coming to New York and the
success that he had and like experiences
of racism in the fashion industry and
his role what I say what he about like
being black and fashion well like for a
very long time he was the most powerful
black person in fashion until the new
editor of British editor-in-chief of
British Vogue Edward and right not and
that was in 2018 so I think that he he
you know like loves fashion and loved
his place in fashion but like would love
to see the industry like be more
inclusive
and so he's commentary on that I found
to be really really interesting and
smart and I just like it like broke my
heart when he like had these stories of
prejudices that he experienced or rumors
that people have started about him um
that were rooted in like the fact that
he was black and in this industry so
ultimately I thought it was a great read
if you have any interest in fashion or
subarray memoirs I would highly
recommend it I think it took me about a
day to read but I also his leadership I
was at reading just straight so it was
good it was it was compelling and then
Gabrielle Union's book I loved I I think
I also finished it in a day uh cuz yeah
we were there for like two days but it
was it was so good she is just like the
coolest girl her to Scott like um she
talks a lot about her childhood and just
like you know growing up and like you
know being with boys and this and that
but she talks a lot about being like
just a black girl in the world
a black girl in Hollywood like even
having like her hair and being on to the
set of white movies and like what that
meant for her and just like just these
small things that we probably don't
think about but that are really
important and conversations that we need
to be having and she like just I thought
the way that she just the way that
everything was written like I felt like
I was getting a major education in a lot
of things that I did not previously know
about um and also she there was a
chapter in there about Prince cuz he
used to have nice parties that were like
these mixers the way she described it it
was really interesting so that's where
she met like her husband at one of those
parties but he would have these parties
for like you know people in the
entertainment industry who are at the
top of whatever they're doing but also
like a lot of black people so they
couldn't meet each other and you know
learn from each other and she said when
Prince died there was this whitewashing
of his epic parties in the media where
it's like and people would beg Justin
Timberlake to sing but she was like
being there it's almost as if it was
like Andy Warhol's factory that's what
someone else might have described as
where it's just like this meeting of
and also Andre Leon Talley used to work
like for Andy Warhol so it was like oh
now I know that is and that's right over
here and it was it was just so she just
has such a great take on everything and
also she talked a lot about I know we've
been saying on this show like you know
we don't know what it's like to be like
a black man in this country and n deal
with police officers but she was talking
about raising black children like and so
many of the conversations she's had to
have with them not even about the police
but like when you go to a friend's house
for a sleepover like do not leave the
group do not ever be alone cuz if
something goes missing like they're
gonna blame you and that's not something
I've ever thought about and so she's
just like having all these conversations
are sharing you know things that go on
in her home and it was it was really
powerful I just love her I love her
I've always loved her but like you also
just got the feeling that like she is
just a cool girl you know like yeah and
I feel like I get the vibe from her like
she just has it figured out like
everything you know and I just like want
to be with her and her family yeah but
you know what I think what she says a
lot in the book it's like it it took
time you know she's married before Duane
and it wasn't good and you know there
was like times in her career that
weren't great and so you know it's all
about how you how you go through it
right and you got to finish strong not
that she's like finishing but you know I
mean ya know I mean and then she's on
the cover of self in a photo taken by
her daughter daughter yeah um that's
fabulous I actually might read that in
an in four months so the next time I
need to read a bi think II would love
that
the Gabrielle Union but but you know
what I realize cuz I've been reading
more I think I just read more in this
summer I'm not really a winter reader
okay your seasonal reader but I also I
don't want to Kindle like I like a
physical book so I'll have to wait for
hers to come in the mail okay do it um
now we're gonna recap our toast movie of
the week which I just [ __ ] loved like
okay so we watched Jess mercy last week
and then we're also gonna sign our movie
for next week one more time Jess Murphy
mercy starring Michael B Jordan and
Jamie Foxx was like I actually didn't
have words I sobbed the entire time and
we said this with hidden big ears like
probably my favorite types of movie are
the ones that are based on true bands
and then at the end you get to learn
more see more they both looked so much
like the characters that they play like
with the hair and everything it was so
well done it was and then I just learned
so much about equal justice initiative
and Brian Steven Stephenson who is
incredible and I just loved it so much
like it was very painful at times like I
the scene where um Johnny D sell me uh
herb Herbert herb was put to death was
indescribable I don't even know how I
was just it was awful like it was the
worst thing I'd ever seen
ya know that that scene got me like I
mean I was crying the entire time it was
it was painful to watch at times
ultimately like it's a pretty happy
ending for Johnny D and and his family
and then you know it gets you going on
this journey of what the equal justice
initiative has done and they share a lot
of other stories like his other some
mate who was in there for 30 years until
it was who was innocent right he's on
death row for thirty [ __ ] years and
when they showed the real footage of him
walking out of the courthouse and
hugging his family like I just about ya
know I had already lost at that point I
can't remember the last time like I
cried so much during a movie I know a
lot of people are recommending a lot of
movies right now and like so many of
them are so educational and pertinent to
the situation but like this movie I
think is the number one and there's a
reason why it's the one that is free to
stream on all streaming services it'll
change your life like I just I knew that
there was a problem and they say like
mass incarceration is modern-day slavery
and when he drove up to the courthouse I
mean the gym for the first time and
there was all these black men in Slyke
prison jumpsuits working in the field it
really was like a fly
like it was I thought the same thing too
early it was just it was insane and the
movie
I always knew like like of course the
the justice system doesn't always get it
right but like to make such a grave
error multiple times with literally it
wasn't even hard to figure out that
Johnny D didn't do it like that's what
he's saying and it's like of course not
every time is gonna be right but like it
wasn't even possible that he killed this
person and like he sat on death row and
to me the biggest disgrace was his
roommate ray thirty [ __ ] years like
it just it was infuriating like just to
see such a gross miscarriage of justice
and such such obvious [ __ ] racism
from these [ __ ] people in Alabama
like it was just it was fury ating yeah
it was infuriating like how hard I had
to work to make what is so obvious clear
to people and then when even when they
did the first trial like to just get a
retrial and it was like it was all there
and then one month later it comes down
and and there's not enough like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you I totally agree and you know
it's like I thought a lot about that guy
Ralph who gave false testimony and it's
like can you [ __ ] blame him look what
they did to him yeah send him to death
row like it's just so corrupt just to
what get a conviction and that the end
of the day it's like justice for the
girl who was shot you know right where
is the murderer
like what do you just do this hard to
find a real murder as you're gonna try
to frame a black man like stop it was
just it was it was infuriating yeah it
wasn't pure it was truly impure eating
but I was I'm so glad to learn about the
work of Bryan Stevenson um and to
continue learning about it obviously
I thought of Kim and that is like horrid
she is trying to do and I have even more
like just more of an appreciation
understanding and like understanding
truly it's like that's what we're trying
to do with these movies that were
watching is just like learn and get our
head
out of our own bubble and like I really
honestly find these like especially this
movie it was an education in something
that I that I thought I knew something
about but it's so much more a thousand
percent and it just offered like a
unique opportunity to learn about equal
justice initiative which a might not
have known about which is in the movie
and it's a real [ __ ] organization and
I donated to it last night like and I
just felt like I just wanted them to
keep going over 140 people they got off
death row like that's incredible like
that's unheard of like yeah
organizations like that like deserve to
be in the spotlight they deserve to be
spoken about the deserve to be donated
to because it's really important like
it's just it was it was such a good
movie and like I was mad that I hadn't
seen the earlier but I feel like it
changed the way that I saw the world for
the rest of my life yeah also I haven't
watched 13th yet on Netflix but I intend
to but I heard that Bryan Stevenson is
in that a lot because he's like an
expert on the subject so I know I'm
gonna be less yeah that'll be great to
watch but our next
toast movie of the week which I haven't
seen have you a scene mmm great I'm I've
heard such good things is black Klansmen
yes Adam driver Spike Lee right mm-hmm
okay fabulous I'm not sure where it's
available but I'm sure it's somewhere
yeah and yeah I'm looking forward to it
as well it was Oscar buzzy so you know
now I'm know what people are talking
about at the Oscars and it came really
highly recommended so thanks to everyone
who recommended it and we're gonna recap
it on Friday yes we are going to recap
it on Friday and every Friday we are
going to be highlighting black owned
businesses and we were going to do that
today but we're gonna push it to
tomorrow because we are working with a
fabulous brand and we just need to work
out all the little kinks so that'll be
tomorrow
um and I'm really looking forward to
that yeah me too okay well I think that
all she wrote she wrote this jackhammer
he's just in my ear no sorry she wanted
me to tell you Claudia's special comes
out in a day is June 30th my comedy
special my debut comedy special my first
comedy special I worked so hard on it
you can pre-order it right now on iTunes
you can tap the link in my bio on girl
with no job or just
search disgraced Queen in the iTunes
Store
it is my baby you might probably enjoy I
would really appreciate you guys
purchasing if you can and maybe leaving
over vu8 days I can't [ __ ] wait I
love you guys and now that's all she
wrote
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning sure we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time and YouTube so Rochester
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcasts and
we're podcasting me town so it's not if
I actions hit your public video I
already customized all the places where
we listen podcast by that's more
interesting 5 Serbia but a bit for
something is where we are we'd love you
guys have a great day
hi